like i just think that like women come  more from a place like and i'm a pretty  logical girl but like yeah i feel like  even i feel like the most logical girls  we acknowledge that we're emotional or  emotional beings we kind of look to men  to be more logical you know you've never  noticed a difference in the emotions  between men and women during the time of  the month women have like more mood  swings so just in general like women  because you said you think it's equal  and i'm just shocked because you know  what i meant i feel like we equally in  situations equally naturally  not all the time but i feel like it's do  you think you're an emotional male as in  being in touch with my emotions yeah  yeah  yeah i'm not  stone cold  sometimes it's so especially like  relationships it's so hard to  communicate with you guys